Hello and welcome everyone.
We have a very special guest with us here today,
all the way from Montreal.
Chances are,
if you've enjoyed the writings of Warren Buffett,
if you've hard check,
I pay speak here,
you are very likely going to enjoy the message that Francoise Rashawn has to
share with us today.
He's one of the investors who's letters I highly admire.
I love reading all of your communications.
I love the clarity in your talks.
And the special thing for us as Googlers is,
um,
this is one of the most successful value investors in the world today who
started off as an engineer.
So without giving away too much,
uh,
I'd like to welcome France or Russia.
[inaudible].
So,
uh,
thank you very much for inviting me.
I'm really honored to be here and uh,
I want to do to go do a presentation and I call it the art of investing.
So yes,
I was trained as an engineer.
I also had a very big passion for art.
So when I started you already capital,
probably you have gas that as you've already is the name of a city where they
lived.
And so you see a little painting of 12 Monday on the,
the first line.
So the art of investing,
it's,
I call it the art of going beyond the numbers.
So,
um,
I got the idea really you by reading Peter Lynch book one up on Wall Street.
And he said that investing in stocks is a nar more than science.
And you know,
people that were trained to think very rigidly to quantify everything.
It's a big disadvantage when they invest in the stock market.
So we're gonna start with that.
And um,
so as an engineer I was trained with this scientific education.
So we're trained to develop a rational mind.
You need to understand numbers.
And I think it's a big advantage because there's a lot of financial belief that,
you know,
people that are trained in the finance business.
I think the,
the learning things that I believe are not to really scientific and we don't
need to unlearn those things,
but at the same time a scientific education.
I think as some disadvantages when you,
when it comes to the stock market,
we're trained to look at past numbers on the belief that the future will be
similar human.
Sometimes it don't be a black hat on.
So you have to understand that the financial world is
a very strange world.
And when you trained to think very rigidly,
it's hard sometimes to understand what's happening and has a scientific,
we're trained not to judge,
but to gather facts and judgment is a big part of the s talking investing
process.
And also we're trained to be very precise and right,
but investing is about being on precise and precise and also accepting don't,
it'd be wrong,
30 35 40% of the time.
And that's a good ratio.
So I wouldn't have,
just to put a quote via one of the great engineer of all time,
he collect test line said that instinct is something that is important in
science.
It transcends knowledge.
And the,
I think that's a very interesting a quote.
But at the same time there's a big difference between arts,
science and alchemy and you know during many centuries outcome is try to change
lab in gold and that's not really science.
And so this idea that I have a great feeling about that stuff,
that's not really our neither.
It is investing.
It's really just being lazy.
So if you want to be an artist and the investing world,
well you want to master that art.
So you want first choose a nar that true you really love,
you want to study the masters of that art.
And also it's important that as master paints,
investor invest,
so you want to be active in your art and you want also to develop your own style
of an independent mind and always try for improvements.
And I have this quote by Woody Allen and they said that in order to be a jazz
musician you have to listen to jazz.
And it's,
it's an act of love.
You listen to music not because you want to learn it,
but because you enjoy it.
And gradually you've kind of a system of Osmosis it,
you know,
it learn into you.
And that's I think any art that you want to learn the have to go to it to an act
of love.
And then I have this quote by Jim Collins.
He said that,
uh,
you can either follow a paint by number of Kipp approach to life or you can
decide to want to create your own masterpiece.
And in the investing world if you want to be original and you have to accept
that probably you will be different from the others.
And we'll probably a half to be eccentric rash,
unconventional m that's a quote by John Maynard Keynes.
He wrote a book called a state of longterm expectation,
1936.
And it's a,
is the longterm investor that in practice will be very different from the others
and probably criticize on some point because it says in the essence of his
behavior that TLV eccentric rash and unconventional in the eyes of the average
opinion,
that means that,
uh,
if you want to obtain better results in the stock market,
you have to be able to stand in your own and you'll be different than the
typical crowd of investor.
And that's sometimes hard to,
it's fun when you look at that picture.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it's sometimes the whole heart because you have to be different than that
African,
sometimes a very contrarian opinion than the average view on this,
either a stock or the stock market in general.
So let's look at the results of money managers in general in our investing
world.
Those,
so that's the normal bell curve of the typical results has investors.
And this line here is the SNP 500 and the s and p 500 is not right in the middle
for this.
It's very simple reason that managers charge fees.
So they,
you know,
from scratch,
they owe their start from the,
uh,
probably one or 2% of the ids and p 500.
So just because of that,
the SNP 500 probably beats up 85% of the investors.
So you want always to think what not to do if you want to beat the index.
So if you want to beat the normal distribution,
what do you want not to do while if you think the same ways as most investors
and you have the same time Arisun who probably,
and I would the same results.
So also if you own lots of companies,
it's very hard to differ from the index.
And I would have to that if you believe that you're smarter than the others and
you can predict the stock market,
I think a,
it's a road to failure.
So what do you want to do if you want to be the normal curve?
Well,
so far and the last 24 years we've probably been in the top 1% on investors.
So that's hope it's not pure luck.
And uh,
that we do have an investment approach that helps up to be the index.
So what do we do?
We tried to think for ourselves,
we try to be own very few selected companies and develop the right behaviors,
which I'll go through a little later.
But these are rationality,
humility and patience.
So perhaps we can go to our stock selection process.
So that's the science part of it.
So we started with this financial strength of the companies.
We want companies that have higher return on capital that grown their earnings
per share that also at the same time I've had strong balance sheets of the deck
to profit ratio.
Usually you would want some tag lesson four times and we want a business model
that is very solid.
So we want companies that are market leaders that af competitive advantage and
low cyclicality and the competitive advantage is very important.
Then I'll go back to that point a little later.
The management team.
So we want,
uh,
you know,
the CEO,
the CFO,
the high,
the high management team to own lots of shares in the company.
So you want a high level of ownership.
So they really in the same boat as we are.
Uh,
we want,
you know,
managers that have good capital allocation skills.
They make constructive acquisitions and you know,
they really think long term when they make investments.
And then we have market valuation.
So we want to start that will purchase at a level that,
you know,
we can double our money over five years,
which is something that a 15% annual return.
So,
you know,
without being very precise because we know that probably is an illusion and when
you try to be too precise,
we tried to have a view of what we think the company can earn in five years and
it's going to help us to moralize what kind of valuation and we can expect,
uh,
during that time.
Few words about art.
At first I want to say that art and beauty are in some ways until are
interrelated.
And you know,
very few money managers talk about beauty,
but I think it's important.
How do you define beauty in the investment world?
Why would we say that?
Beauty usually to our eyes.
It's something I,
it's rare.
We usually find something beautiful when it's something that we sell them.
See.
So,
and something that is unique is we never see.
So it's really the rarest of all the beauties.
And I always,
sometimes when I read an annual report and look at the numbers when I have this
feelings,
while this is a beautiful company,
it turns high return on capital.
It has much better margin than their competitors.
You know,
this,
that's something that lights up in my mind.
So what you want is to find what I call masterpieces.
And they have one quality.
They're rare and unique.
So I've taken some example in the art world.
So the Monalisa a Rothko painting events on Van Gogh painting.
And if you want to take some example of business masterpieces while I've gone to
the history of the capitalist world,
mostly in the u s and you know,
we can start with probably the one of the first technology company in the 1880s
called national cash register.
That's probably heard of,
uh,
your attacker that many years ago,
whether a very innovative company,
apple,
Ika,
uh,
Tj Maxx,
Geico,
the other insurance company owned by Berkshire,
a Washington Post HR block,
Donlin brasserie [inaudible] to McDonald's,
Starbucks.
I think all these companies,
and we could certainly add Google the,
that cloth.
These are business masterpieces.
So you want to study those kinds of businesses and see what do they have that
was so unique and the uniqueness and either the product or the service or the
culture is equivalent of having a boat that protect your castle,
your economy,
Castle from invaders,
which you know,
our competitors.
So that's a key thing.
You want to own a mode with lots of crocodiles and parents,
piranhas and it,
so you know,
competitors don't want to come near your castle.
So if we could resume kind of what we look for in a company,
it's really tree things.
And the competitive advantages,
which we could say is the artistic part of that.
The financial strength,
which is really the science part and the management team.
And this is where judgment comes into play.
It's very important to be able to judge management.
And you know,
that's kind of subjective thing when you're talking about judgment.
But you know how we say,
I have this phrase that when you meet the management,
you ask yourself,
would I like this man who married my daughter?
And if their answer is yes,
it's probably a good man to,
to be partner with.
So we ended up with something 125 stocks that fit that criteria was,
and the one that we do buy for the portfolio are the ones that fit our criteria
as in terms of market valuation that we can buy at a price today that we hope we
can earn some pay 15% going forward yearly.
So perhaps just take a few examples,
uh,
for,
to,
uh,
to illustrate our approach.
While one company I think is very unique is a Walt Disney.
They have great brand name,
they own the star wars franchise.
Uh,
the own of course hold those are historical stars like Mickey Mouse and we need
a pool.
And they bought marvel a few years back.
And,
um,
you know,
I always say that Mickey Mouse says tree great qualities.
Uh,
first is highly popular,
very unknown all around the world.
Second is immortal and the third he has no agent.
So you really own your star.
And that's a great thing for Disney and the unique in this a business model of
Disney is that they have these um,
big movie blockbusters and like how Alison Wonderland in 1951 and then 50 years
later and they can redo a new version and make money again with the same name.
And they did that recently with the jungle book.
Uh,
they released their first animated version in 1967 and they did a real live
version last year,
which shows we'll also a big success.
So it's kind of like a owning an oil field while you take all the oil and 50
years later you go back to the field and there's even more new oil to take out
and don't need to spend money on capital and you know,
pay people to,
to,
to guard your field.
It's really an extraordinary business model.
We bought that stock probably 11,
12 years ago.
Uh,
I think in 2005,
we paid about $24 and it was,
uh,
the date above Iger wasn't Mco and that we've done it since then.
So there was a period when this stock did not do much.
As you can see before,
years of stock didn't do very well,
but earnings kept growing.
And we were a patient.
And the,
if you look over the 12 years we've owned this top,
her name is,
I've grown about 13% annually and then the end of the stock has a more than
quadruple.
So if your patient and companies grew there,
if their value,
eventually this talk will follow.
I want to take another example of a stock that's been a one portfolio,
a carmax.
It's been 10 years in the portfolio and that has,
you can see earnings per share of corona of about 16% annually since we bought
it in 2007.
And the stock has done very similar.
Uh,
even though the p ratio is a little lower today than when we first bought it,
we first bought into the summer of 2007.
At that time,
the Pe ratio was about 24 times.
We bought more shares in 2011 and that 14 times and more shares in 2016 again at
14 times.
And today the stock is about 18 times earnings.
So even though the p ratio has been reduced a bit all over the years,
the stock has done pretty well.
It's not about 13% annually.
Uh,
even though earnings grow grew about 16% on early,
and that's about a 5% better than the s and p 500.
They've been an included as done about 8% annually over the last decade.
So it's been a good investment.
Um,
I want to say few words about a competitive advantage as investors at Giverny.
What kind of competitive advantage can we have?
Well,
first,
um,
I think it's tree things,
patients your and rationality,
a humility.
I think we do believe that it's impossible to predict macroeconomic events,
so we don't try to predict them.
Uh,
also one key element,
a key element is to focus on your circle of competence and to know where the
limits of that circle is.
And thirdly,
we want to recognize our mistakes when we do them and always try to improve our
stock selection process.
A few awards on the timing of purchases.
I would the guy and uh,
said that the 80% of success is showing up.
And so that's one of the main reason we always want to be invested in the stock
market because we believe that owning great companies,
not trying to predict the stock market is the key thing to be able to beat the
index over the long run.
And by always striving for improvement,
we try to study a mistakes in details.
So each year on an annual that,
or we have this yearly metals that we give to our best mistakes,
then it's a very popular part of our annual letter.
I don't know why,
but uh,
uh,
because it's very painful.
But,
uh,
I think that's very important.
If you want to continue to improve yourself.
A few words on rationality.
Uh,
we try not to be affected when others make more money to,
I'm not asking stops because there's always fans and you know,
we don't get into fat.
So sometimes we'll be,
you know,
different from what's going on in the very popular part of the soft market.
But,
you know,
we try to be rational and say,
well,
if it's,
if we don't really understand it,
if we can,
don't think that's a,
you know,
a good area,
what we are,
where our capital should be invested,
we just take you away from it.
And we tried to be improved and used to the stock market,
a quotation in the short run.
So it takes a lot of rationality because the stock market can be very,
very volatile.
So,
uh,
we try to always be,
you know,
uh,
calm and trying to always have to high on the long term horizons of the company
we purchase and we accept that we don't know the future.
And we tried to focus on,
you know,
part of the process that we can control.
It's really to,
like I said,
to look for companies that we understand that we believe that have a competitive
in a ditch and you know,
we accept that we don't know exactly I'll,
things were workout.
But you know,
if you own great companies with great managers,
eventually you should be okay.
And that comes up too is something we,
uh,
we put out a few years back,
I call it the rule of three.
It's really to accept that one year out of the three to stock markets will
declining by 10% or more.
One stop purchase out of three will not perform as expected and one year out of
three you will underperform the index.
Then that's the best manager is usually underperform one year of three.
So it's a,
it's still a very ambitious,
a rule,
a group of rule.
But,
uh,
if you accept that from the start,
when you'll have some bad years on some bad investments,
you'll be better prepared psychologically to deal with that.
And the few word on patients,
well,
the saying that a patient is not the ability to wait,
but the ability to keep a good attitude while waiting.
So what's the good attitude in the investment world?
It's really to focus on what's happening the company.
That's what's happening to the stock.
And that's a sometimes a hard thing to do.
But if you go back to the example of Carmax,
carmax stock over the last decade has been quite volatile.
It went down 25% a few times.
But if you look at the earnings over those 10 years,
it's been a pretty stable business.
So if you just focus on what's happened to car Max over the last 10 years,
I think beside 2009 earnings went up every year and it grow are earnings by more
than the percent early.
So just focus on that and forget about the,
the stock price movements you'll be okay.
But,
uh,
I want to say another word about patients.
That's not the same thing as being stubborn.
And sometimes we fail to recognize mistakes we make.
So I like to think about the analogy of a,
how do you get the frog to be cooked?
If you put it in boiling water,
it will jump out of the bowls.
So what you do,
you put it on a mild water and slowly increase of temperature and you know the
frog one get out because she always think while things are getting a little
hotter,
but they'll cooldowns eventually.
So,
and you know,
it never cools down and eventually get cooked.
So what you want is not to buy a stock and you know,
earning is a little disappointing.
Different metals start to deteriorate,
the stock go down,
but you don't want to sell out a loss.
So,
uh,
when you know,
investment doesn't work very well,
I try to focus on what's happening to the company and to be sure that I'm not
getting,
you know,
Cook like a frog.
And that's really,
that's really important.
And there's a big difference and knowing when to keep your shares because of
fundamentals,
warrants it and recognize who made a mistake and just get out of that stock.
And that's a big,
that's a big difference between being patient and stubborn.
So,
um,
to summarize what differentiate an artistic investor and let's say the
conventional investor,
that typical investor in the stock market,
either professional or a Matar,
it's really the focus on market quotes.
There are short term oriented,
do you have opinion on everything?
And they tried to predict when to buy stocks and the cannot resist the latest
fad.
So I would say the end conventional investor,
while he focuses on intrinsic value,
you as a long term horizon is agnostic about many,
many things including where the stock market will be in a few weeks or a few
months.
And at the same time he doesn't try to predict when to buy,
but he focuses more on what to buy.
And I wouldn't say the right verb is what to own.
And of course he rescinded you resist the fads and the popular group and it's
easy to ride in a present nation,
but it's harder on the day to day to resist or what's been very popular.
So that takes a lot of independence of thought ever leave.
So why it's an investor must be able to kind of balance many things.
So I talked about the law of,
for the art,
but that same time you want to be very rational.
You don't want to fall in love with stocks.
You,
you want us always be rational.
You want to have a very large fields of knowledge and,
and we'll look at many,
many companies,
but at the same times you want to focus on your circle of competence.
You want to be open minded.
But at the same time you have to have independence of thoughts.
We want to be able to value the business.
But at the same time,
like I said in this British Sinn Fein has changed.
You want to be able to go beyond the numbers.
So he's just not numbers.
If it was just numbers and that the mission mathematician would all be
billionaires.
So of course it takes a little more than that.
Um,
you have to have patience,
but as the same time don't want to give cooked like a frog.
And finally you want discipline,
but you want to be able to bring the rules.
So I always say that the discipline is to follow your own rules,
but wisdom is to know when to break your own rules.
So sometimes we've,
we've bought some stock that didn't really fit our criteria was,
but you know,
we made the judgment call that we believe most of the time,
either the business has really something special or the management that's really
something special or ideally both.
So finally,
to summarize in one sentence,
to obtain better results than the others,
I would call the John Templeton.
He said that you have to do something different from the others and you have any
capital.
What do we do differently?
Well,
first we think independently.
We own very few selected company.
We have a very long term horizon,
I mean a thing on the average.
And we own our stocks seven years.
And the typical investor on Wall Street's at seven months.
So that's kind of a 12th who onward 12 to one ratio.
And also we tried to develop the right behaviors.
Gree,
you want to be rational,
humble,
and patient.
So That's control the presentation.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Fantastic.
So folks,
I'm gonna read something for you guys.
I think you might find this interesting.
So good business plan.
Our business women are like artists.
They have to do something with passion,
something innovative and unique that will last and that will inspire others.
In the final process,
I try to figure out how much this marvelous companies should be worked and try
to buy it in the market.
F at half of what I believe it should trade in five years if everything goes as
planned,
which is about 15% a year.
So these two paragraphs are from an interview of France who are in the year 2005
and I'm sure it,
it's kind of obvious how consistent your philosophy has been over the years.
It's remarkable.
It's sort of in the Francoise Roshaun of 2005 would have probably given the same
talk in very similar words as I can tell.
So what I want to ask you is,
has it been easy for you to follow this approach consistently?
Has it been tested over the years?
Have there been times where you've questioned and sort of how you've thought
about it?
These things.
Yeah,
it's fantastic because I can,
like I said,
we have to accept that we underperform one year that was the tree.
And you know,
in the good years it's easy to say,
but when those barriers happen,
uh,
it's really painful.
And you know,
when you have some partners,
uh,
while the words you use for clients,
you have to explain to them where,
why you have a bad year and uh,
sometimes can be tough and it can last more than one year.
It can be two or three years in a row.
So that's a,
I think it takes a lot of conviction that uh,
you're on the right path and you're doing what you think is the best for you
know,
your partners.
And then,
uh,
I think if the,
if the principles are sound eventually,
uh,
the,
there were workout.
So again,
the importance of our patients,
I think that's probably the most important quality you need when you invest in
the stock market.
So two people who are listening to this talk,
there might be young graduate students,
people who are getting into the investing profession or a lot of individual
investors like ourselves who are saying,
this is a good approach.
Maybe I want to try it.
And you know,
they could have a couple of bad years to start off with.
And uh,
uh,
what is your advice there?
Um,
I think there's the patients also.
It's Pr,
it's important of course,
but I think the,
there's a quality behind patients and s humility.
You have to accept that you'll make some mistakes and there's always things that
you can learn.
And how I would say that,
uh,
the greatest quality,
Warren Buffett is not necessarily an intelligence is the humility.
I mean,
he's the greatest investor of all time is a greatest wall,
but it's still very humble,
always looking to improve and learn.
And I think that's six greatest qualities,
87 years old and he's still striving for new,
uh,
new learning every day.
You always want to learn new things and understand new things.
And if you have those qualities,
I think that's a,
I think you,
you'll succeed in almost every anything.
Yeah,
you do.
That's very interesting because you know,
he's been quoted to have said in interviews that if you have an Iq of 160,
you might be better off giving 10 points to say,
I think you said selling.
Selling.
Sure.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So you do believe that,
you know,
it's more than the Iq,
it's the behavioral traits after a point that are critical.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so any advice to individual investors,
young investors who might not be professional investors like yourself?
What are some best practices
can adopt?
Um,
I think,
yeah,
you have,
first you have to look for company yet you can't understand because there's
many,
many companies out there,
there's thousands and thousands and you know,
it's hard to really understand all of those companies and some are just very,
very complicated.
So you're trying to play a hard game when you want to be able to value every
company.
You play an easier game when you're very selective and you just go for companies
that you can understand that it goes back to the analogy of a Ted Williams that
he wanted to wait for the perfect pitch that was in the sweet spot zone.
And uh,
I think that's the beautiful thing of thing about the stock market.
Then Warren Buffett said that many,
many years ago that the investing is a greatest business of all because,
uh,
that's the one you can choose the ball you wanna hit.
So you have to luxury of sending at the plate and you know,
we're waiting for the perfect ball.
There's no cold strike.
And that's,
I think the most beautiful thing in the investment business.
But at the same time,
um,
it's a very competitive and vesting world.
So there's some disadvantage do.
But if you have the right behavior,
the right approach,
and you're very patient and very,
uh,
selective,
I think in the end you'll,
you'll succeed.
Great.
So in your presentation fracture,
you said,
uh,
you know,
there's an element of beauty sometimes you recognize it.
Yeah.
And you also say that there is science and mathematics of investing.
And I was wondering if we could take,
you know,
one company as an example.
Uh,
one of the logos on your
slides was I think Starbucks.
Yeah.
Um,
and I'm sure like a lot of people here recognize the company.
So can you describe what you see in terms of,
you know,
the qualitative,
the beauty,
like aspects and you know,
like you said,
what are the earning potential is five years from now?
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
Starbucks,
I looked at it,
I think the first time was in 1994.
And,
uh,
I thought that was a unique business.
And I remember coming to the u s uh,
in the early nineties,
and you know,
drinking coffee and the hotels and was in a bad coffee.
And you know,
I said,
well,
if you go any telly,
you are,
yeah,
in France you have great coffee,
but you can to the greatest country in the world and you,
your drink bad coffee and says it didn't make sense.
And when I first try Starbuck,
I said,
well,
these people aren't do something and they'll do well.
And that I remember,
uh,
I mean the Howard Schultz was a very ambitious and very driven,
the CEO.
And he was very confident that it could be Starbucks,
could have thousands and thousands and thousands of coffee,
uh,
stands everywhere in us and in the world.
And,
um,
I thought the,
I thought it was indeed possible and the Ozo coffee better than Tim Horton's.
Oh yeah.
But you know,
I want to be pitched me,
I'll take you here.
Say a Tim Hortons it a great company also because it's getting again,
but the,
you know,
if I had to have coffee,
I'll go work at Starbucks.
And the,
you know,
the only thing that prevented me to invest 23 years ago was the p ratio
Starbuck.
And I remember it was trading at 40 times earnings.
And you know,
that was way too high for me,
but I don't know,
I didn't look lately because it's too painful,
but the stock is probably a hundred fold since then.
So it's been a wonderful company,
a wonderful stock,
and never owned it.
So what penetration,
you know,
40 is maybe too expensive with what might be a PE ratio?
Very good marriage,
Europe
pension.
Well,
with some insight,
I would say that 40 times earnings in 94 was cheap because you know,
it didn't at all this candida future growth would come,
but you want a big margin of safety.
And um,
I think was in 1949 that Ben Graham said that the cornerstone of a on the
intelligent investing is margin of safety.
So if you pay a very high p reassure,
you don't have as much safety as you,
if you pay a lower p ratio.
But is it 20,
is it 25 is it's 15.
That's where the judgment comes into play to help you design.
No,
I think I'm trying to sort of make it more practical for people who are
listening just to,
um,
you know,
I think today it's like 23,
24 times PE ratio.
And,
uh,
would that sort of a metric,
bring it,
Eh,
you know,
you said you had 125,
would it come up in those for you to look at,
for example?
Well,
I think,
uh,
management is great.
I think the business model is great.
Uh,
just have to ask yourself where it is today.
Will they be able to continue to grow at a superior growth rate going forward?
Which I would define 12% or more.
Uh,
I mean,
every company,
even the greatest companies in the whole history,
they come to a point where they hit maturity and it's harder to grow at the
higher a high growth rate.
So I mean,
growing earnings at eight or nine or 10%,
that's still quite an achievement,
but it's not as,
uh,
you know,
exciting growing at 15% or more a year.
So it's kind of be probably harder for Starbucks.
But I've been saying that for a few years that being wrong so far.
So,
so maybe let's just take a step back.
Funds for the audience here.
What are some areas in the market where you do see,
you know,
both the elements of beauty and out of value today?
Uh,
well I think we took the example of Carmax and I think that's a company that I
believe can grow by about 15% annually for many,
many years.
Revenues,
earnings while probably earnings or revenue is for me closer to 10%.
But you know with some,
some margin expansion and some by backup chair,
the thing they can attain at 15% growth in earnings per share and then trades
that 18 times earnings.
So the PE ratio is similar than the market,
but the thing that growth profile is probably twice as twice as good.
Okay.
Now I have
a couple of questions.
Just typically we ask all of our guests,
um,
what are some of your favorite like managers or business people that you look
at?
And then the second part of the question is what are some books,
you know,
investing in non and last thing that you learned,
joy that you might want to share with us?
Well managers,
um,
well I have a deep respect for mark and there that constellation software,
I think he's a really,
he's an artist.
He's really unique,
is a really original and uh,
and uh,
he has a very,
very long term horizon and everything he does.
And I think constellation software,
which you know,
is a Canadian company,
uh,
I think,
I hope it continues to be,
but uh,
if you looked at it today,
it's really a masterpiece.
It's really something quite unique and a great culture and great artists at the
Ham.
It's interesting you bring it up cause it's a technology company typically by
learn westerners sort of,
you know,
they've had this rough interaction with like being in technology versus not
being there.
And also it's one of those companies that has grown by acquisitions.
Uh,
which again,
value investors tend to shy away from.
So how do you look at those
two aspects?
I say there's many ways to get rich.
So
Starbucks is just having one concept and they could clone it thousand times.
And others company,
I mean,
Berkshire Hathaway.
That's an example of a company that grew by acquisition.
It's an holding company that now have a,
we could say a hundreds of the divisions.
So there's many way.
Yeah.
Duana I mean,
and Mcdonald's for many years at just a little bit like about one concept that
they,
they need the calm many times.
So I think that in the end,
what really counts is over,
let's say a decade.
It's the growth in earnings per share.
So if you have a great business model,
if,
uh,
you have great seasoning management and he said,
great return on capital,
it will translates into a earnings per share growth,
which,
uh,
will translate it into a stock that will go up.
So if you pay a reasonable price and the earnings per share quadruple over a
decade,
there's a good chance that the stock will do the same
when you apply the earnings per share concept to a company like,
you know,
bookshare you mentioned,
but even mark health for example,
you know,
an insurance company where you may not realize the earnings because you know,
they're just piling up on the balance sheet.
Yeah.
Well in terms of for Berkshire Mark,
our probably a price to book is a better,
it's not perfect,
but this is probably a better way to value.
And you use a ratio,
I think,
uh,
for both companies 1.5 1.6 times book value would make sense because that's the
nature of their business.
That's a,
the yearnings are more erratic.
So you have to value in some other way.
So you have to adapt to the business model,
the business,
your friends who we had one of our guests,
they brought up a very interesting concept.
They said,
you know,
you look at all these great companies and you recognize that,
there is a mode and you know,
the past 10 or 15 years they've displayed that in their numbers and then you sit
back and ask yourself in the future,
may not necessarily be identical to the past.
So they said what really matters is,
you know,
they're the moat we growing.
It doesn't matter whether it's site,
smaller,
big.
So how do you think about growing or modes or margin,
most versus established modes?
Uh,
that's very hard because I most always keep changing.
And,
uh,
I remember a few years back,
Charlie Munger said that,
uh,
I had the,
I ask a question to Charlie about molds and all those great companies that seems
to see they're both shrinking.
And he said,
well,
I know all those molds are getting filled with sand.
And so,
um,
I asked him,
which company do you think as an expanding mode?
And that was six years,
seven years ago,
I said that Google interests,
I think that's an incredibly covered,
incredible company.
And I remember thinking,
well,
I knew about Google off of course,
but,
uh,
I said,
well,
I should take a new look at it.
And,
uh,
we,
we bought chairs in 2000 and live in after,
after that comment.
So,
uh,
we were lucky because at that time their p ratio was 15 times.
So if it would have been a few points higher,
probably would have a past and miss the increased 400% since then.
So,
um,
there's always new companies with both,
some are expanding,
some of our shrinking,
so we have to follow that closely.
But they finally had to choose one criteria to help me decide what's the
direction of the mold.
Because the managers,
I mean,
those moles are not built by angels.
They're built by humans beings.
So what makes a both grow,
I think is something in the culture of the company.
And they'll,
things doesn't come from thin air.
It comes from the top management that builds that culture and then it translate
them to a mope and then high return on equity for the shareholders.
So when you look at the high returns of equity over the last 10 years,
do you say it was because of the culture or are there other things beyond just
the numbers that you try and study to identify whether this is a culture and you
want to be associated with?
Well,
there's many things.
Uh,
it's really,
uh,
what's the nature of the products?
What's the nature?
You know,
the funny thing with Google,
it was not the first company that,
uh,
had a search engine on the Internet,
the last one that come up with a new,
a search engine.
But this one was better than the others.
Uh,
thinking,
uh,
yeah,
well I'll tell [inaudible] or those first companies that,
that search engine,
so sometimes the first arrival and sometimes strangely it's the last arrival.
So,
uh,
that's the,
that's the tough thing with investing.
Every story is new and different.
So you have to,
when I said it's important to have an open mind,
it's because if you have this very strict frame to analyze companies,
probably you miss lots of things because every situation is new and the future
is all the oils,
uncharted territory.
So you have to have some principles,
uh,
you look for certain things,
but in the end you have to judge every a situation differently and by they own
pair of meters.
And if you look at our portfolio,
we own something at 25 companies.
And I think the,
the reason we invested in dose 25 differ very much from one to the other
sometimes to really because of the management.
And sometimes it's really because we think the brand is very solid and sometimes
we think the company has lots of room to grow and it's just like a Starbucks
where they just have to clone the concept that they built.
So
there's no one recipe.
It's really to have an adaptive mine and trying to understand the nature of the
business you want to invest into it.
Okay.
So that leads into my next question actually,
which is,
you know,
when do you decide to sell?
You said your average holding period is about seven years and you invest in
quality companies and you know,
you give the example of Carmax,
which you've been holding on for several years.
Um,
but it's all the company like Intel,
if I remember correctly.
Yeah.
So can you talk about,
you know,
how you think about selling companies because you think of yourself as a
partner.
So it must be an emotional process as well maybe.
But yeah,
we tried to remove it,
high emotion
from the process,
but it's never easy because we're,
we're human beings so or emotional.
So we have to accept that.
Then sometimes accepting it and going beyond said,
well,
that's why we have those uh,
rules or process that helps them make decision.
And this really for reason,
we'll sell stock.
The first one they realize we made a mistake that's happened.
And I don't know the ratio.
It's probably one,
I'll have three or four stars that we buy.
For some reason we've made a mistake.
And,
um,
the thing to do is just sell except that that's part of the process and you're a
human being and it's a tough world outside,
uh,
and so tough world.
And uh,
so when you made a mistake,
just tell them,
go into some other investment.
The second reason it's a little different is that he didn't really made a
mistake,
but the nature of the business has changed.
There's a new competitor,
there's a new economic environment,
there's new technology,
whatever,
as change in the industry or the company itself.
It's not as great as when you first purchased it.
So when you realize that you have to sell,
and it can be a year after you bought it,
or 10 years after he bought it.
And the third one is probably when I look at this situation then I don't agree
with a management decision use Uli.
It's a big acquisition.
And when I feel that I don't agree with management,
I just sell.
Okay.
I mean,
uh,
I have this saying that if I am to read you in one sentence what investing is,
it should be gum.
You become partner with the top management.
If you don't trust them anymore,
there's no reason to be partners.
So we sell.
And the fourth reason,
which is probably the most common one,
we just found it an investment that we think has better prospects.
And so we sell a two by be,
not necessarily because there's a problem with a,
but just that we think that we will be more rewarding.
Okay.
And finally,
before we let it out to the audience,
I wanted to talk about my favorite part of your,
I know letters,
which is those metals.
Uh,
and correct me if my memory is failing me,
but was Valliant one of the metals?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
It was a,
yeah,
it was a mistake.
Yeah.
We were lucky because we didn't make money with that,
that an investment,
but they turn out to be a mistake.
Yeah.
So can you talk to the audience,
explain the medals a little bit more and tell us how you give a metal even to
something you call a mistake and still make money out of it?
Well,
I would say there's,
there's a different between being a,
a good and lucky.
So we were lucky there.
So that was still a mistake.
Uh,
basically,
um,
well we make many mistakes and we only choose three to give medals to a bronze,
silver and gold.
And,
uh,
most of the time the mistakes are missions start.
Starbucks as an example is a company that fits all I care,
Tierra.
And we decided not to buy for some sometimes simplistic reason and a,
you,
uh,
you know,
10000% gain over 25 years for that reason.
So,
uh,
we tried to give medals to most costly mistakes and the most costly are usually,
usually missions.
Sometimes it's like value that there was this talk that we did purchase and a,
we made a mistake.
Um,
while in the case of valiant,
I think,
uh,
we have a lot of confidence in the management and uh,
also at the same time that much more debt than we're usually a willing to live
with.
And uh,
we,
we did the kind of an exception to our rules and it turned out that it was a
mistake.
So
what you got out Liam,
before,
you know,
a lot of the other,
yeah,
but the selection wasn't mistake,
so it turned out,
you know,
in the end financially it was okay,
but uh,
that's not,
that's still a mistake.
And that's the hard part.
When you look at your mistakes,
you want to be very objective and say,
well,
this is a mistake for those reasons,
but some stocks that I didn't purchase that went up a hundred times,
but I really didn't understand.
That's not really a mistake.
It's just that you decided that this was outside of your circle of competence
and you missed it.
But that's not really a mistake.
It's a mistake.
When it was in your circle of competence and for some reason you didn't go
through the purchase or it's a mistake when you thought that the company was and
your circle of competence and a and it was not.
So that's basically the two reasons I made a mistake.
We'll be in the chapter of the [inaudible] leather.
It's interesting you separate luck in outcome,
which is what a one of our previous speakers,
Michael Mobile seen talks about,
you know,
skill and luck.
And then Howard marks also say is that,
you know,
he,
when he was here and he said,
you know,
what will happen might be different from what should happen.
So you need to decouple them in your thinking.
But thank you very much.
With that,
let me open it up to the audience if we have any questions for you.
Okay.
Any questions?
What financial?
Yeah.
Hi Fans.
Thank you for the excellent doc.
Thank you.
There's been eating your letters over the years and it's really excellent.
Uh,
one of the questions I wanted to ask you was,
uh,
you were showing us this chart about Walt Disney and buying it at 24 names
earnings,
right?
How do you pay up for good businesses?
Because the,
the times when these businesses are available,
uh,
you know,
with this margin of safety is maybe when something is wrong,
maybe when the market rightly or wrongly thinks that something's off.
Uh,
and if that's not the case,
then how do you pay up?
But if that's the case,
how do you separate what the market is thinking was his reality?
Um,
we tried to focus on the very long term.
So we try to look five years in the future and we come up,
you know,
uh,
with our best judgment,
what we believe the earnings per share should be in five years low.
So let's say Disney,
uh,
we,
when we bought in two five,
we said,
well,
we think this company can earn $3 a share in five years.
And then,
you know,
if you think that the fundamentals will still be good pass those five years,
we'll say,
well it's,
it probably will warrant that p ratio of let's say 20 times.
So that gives you a $60 thousand in five years.
So if you can buy the stock at $30 or less today and you were right on the $60
in five years,
you should be rewarded the,
um,
you know,
earning something 15% annually.
The earning that the company has today is not really relevant to that.
So if they aren't,
the ones are,
uh,
this year,
it looks so pricey at 30 times,
but if you have a longterm horizon and you're focusing on where to sock,
you'll be a,
or the yearnings will be in five years.
Uh,
in the end you'll be okay.
So having this long term are rising,
I believe helps you to defocus the p ratio of today.
And it goes the other way.
If you find a cheap stock,
but you look five years in the future and you don't see any girls prospects,
there's no real reason to believe that the stock will be higher in five years.
It can be a higher end months just because a p has gone from 10 to 12 times.
But,
uh,
we don't try to invest,
which we amounts.
We try and that's what we're faced five years.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for the great talk and welcome to Google.
So,
uh,
I have a question,
considering now the current market conditions,
there's a lot of them warning by people about the risk and there's a lot of fund
managers returning and found to the investors.
So I wonder like,
what do you think about it,
the market in general and a,
what's the race Kenta expect return for them maybe next five,
10 years.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
of course it's not as exciting for an investor today as it was that same 2009
when starts were really,
really cheap.
But you know,
it was Carrie then too.
So,
um,
I always try to kind of the focus what's happening to the market and more focus
on the companies that we own the portfolio.
And when we look at our portfolio and,
uh,
we've got this group of 25 companies that were pretty confident that they'll
grow their earnings by at least 10 to 12% in the next five years under p ratio
seems reasonable.
There's no reason I think,
to,
to be worried.
Uh,
I don't know what the market will do in the next six months,
a year or two.
Uh,
but I think the companies we own in the next five years,
we'll do okay.
And if you look at the general stock market,
we don't have views in general,
but we think that companies can continue to grow their earnings per share,
let's say five to 7% that unruly the next five years,
and you add a dividend to have 2%.
So even though there's no p changes over the next five years,
while that's what translate into a total return for stars for seven to 9%,
so it's not as exciting as eight years ago.
But,
uh,
still it's pretty decent returns when and compare that to bonds with probably he
or something and I less than 2% over the next five years.
So it's not extraordinary exciting to find opportunities,
but I think the returns will be decent mostly for the stocks we own and probably
a stock market as well.
We have one question were there and
see thanks for the talk.
I think a couple of questions.
The first one is I was just looking,
I don't know if it's accurate or not,
I was just looking at the your holdings and I noticed you have like mastercard
yet visa,
mastercard,
you have like I think deposition of 200,
10,000 whereas visa you have like a position at 35 million.
I'm just wondering why you bother keeping mastercard with such a low number
rather than it goes,
he won't even meet,
move the needle.
Right.
Why don't I just put it all into visa because they sit seem to attract each
other anyways,
so that,
that's the first question.
Yeah,
that's a very easy,
uh,
we prefer visa obviously,
and a mastercard.
We all fuel share.
Just to follow it.
But we both think,
we think both companies are great.
These are fantastic businesses.
Uh,
we prefer visa and mastercard just to follow a company we have a few shares is
up because of Visa Europe or just in general think a visa is an extraordinary
business.
And uh,
I think it's hard to say because mastercard is a great business too.
But I think visa as a little something more.
And the second question was in terms of like the big tech stocks,
right?
I mean,
uh,
I noticed you have Google,
so thank you.
But just curious.
Oh Wow.
Thank you.
I I reviewed,
make you give your thoughts on apple.
Why you don't own it?
Because it's got,
I mean,
personally I own,
I own a position there because I think it's got a low valuation and it's got a
very good motor rounded,
especially,
uh,
with all the services added to it.
So just curious on your thoughts on that.
Yeah.
Well obviously apple could be a,
in the section of mistakes because I mean it's sub what,
50 times in the last decade or something like that.
So it's been a great investments.
It's a great company.
I mean I can't argue with that.
And the evaluation does look very low and I think they do have a mold.
And probably five years ago I wasn't that convinced that the mold was that large
and it turned out that it is a very solid business.
Uh,
and I think,
I don't know exactly the number,
but I think today 10% of their revenues are service base and a recurring and as
it get a larger part of the revenue was,
I think that both,
we'll,
we'll be expanding still.
A large part of their revenue was at an earnings come from selling new products.
And when you asked to sell something new every two or three years,
this is a risk that you'll,
you'll miss a,
a product launch or something will not exactly satisfied a customer for whatever
reason or you just have to risk also having another company that comes up with a
new and improved product.
So I think if you compare apple and Google,
I think Google business is more stable and more entrenched and a more recurring
and the thing demote is larger in Google and apple.
That doesn't mean that is not a great business.
And you have to ask yourself a at that prize,
a p ratio differences.
So high,
I think apple trades at 15 times and Google is probably 25 times or if he's not
as close to 30.
So,
um,
while I remember many years ago the pressure,
uh,
and his book that a common stocks and nonconforming profits,
the further in the future you can see growth there.
Hired a p ratio you can pay.
So in the term in terms of visa thing,
you can see the company having their most protective for many,
many years.
It's hard to figure out who could the hurt them.
And a,
you can see many,
many years of growth.
So I think that warrants high PE ratio.
But of course,
uh,
it was better in 2010 when we bought it.
The thing we paid,
I don't know,
15 times or so.
Obviously we had a much larger margin of safety than,
than we have today.
I've got one.
I don't know if that answers your question.
It does.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Maybe cause I noticed one of your largest holdings is Berkshire Hathaway as
well.
And they've taken a big position in apple.
So indirectly you actually probably own more shares of apple through your
holdings.
A Burger,
you have the Internet App.
I don't know if you look into that,
that,
you know,
I own this company and it already gives me exposure so I won't own it
separately.
Do you think?
Well that's not really a reason.
The,
um,
of course when we own Berkshire,
we own apoe and we all Coca Cola and uh,
we own Geico and some Burlington northern Santa Fe and precision Castparts so,
and we get,
and precision Castparts wasn't a portfolio a few years back,
so we're still shareholders.
So,
uh,
but you know,
if we thought that the apple was a good purchase for us today,
uh,
owning Berkshire wouldn't be a reason enough to,
to do it.
Two friends who when you look at something like,
you know,
visa are apo,
you would go to portfolio,
has low debt companies,
sometimes they might even have excess cash.
So when you look the PE ratio,
you take the cash out.
How do you
I think so because I mean that's cash that could be returned to investors.
It's a little harder for apple or Google because a lot of those caches in the
other countries sometimes a little complicated to get back in the u s that cash
and give it to shareholders.
But in the end,
in some ways or the other at this,
this cash will be returned to shareholders.
I hope.
And uh,
I should be taking out of the,
by the way,
but what you want to do is really do this,
some of what you expect the cash to be generated by the company in the future
discounted to today.
And then you add the cash that is today so you get a proper evaluation.
Right.
Well,
it makes sense.
Would that,
uh,
French,
well,
thank you so much for being with us here today.
I really enjoyed your presentation and your dog and thank you all for being such
a great audience.
[inaudible].